i gotta ask about disenchanted um what
can you tell me about what it's been
like to come back to that role it was so
much fun we actually wrapped filming so
uh
we have done it
it was um
it was amazing i get to sing a lot in
that one so
to carry you connor wanted you to have
this and when you're broken on the
ground dear evan hansen he wrote it to
you his last awards conor took his own
life hey what
i'm sorry connor didn't write this no no
no no please
it says you will be fine i just watched
dear evan hansen last night and in the
best way possible i'm emotionally
destroyed you know yeah do you have to
do ice packs this morning
i mean i was gonna ask you because
wow the part that you're playing and you
know i saw it on broadway and you guys
have just done such an incredible job
with the movie but the part you're
playing is
essentially a parent's worst nightmare
right so
how did you take that on how did you
handle it especially being a parent
yourself what was this whole experience
like
you know when i when i saw the musical
which i was introduced to on stage it
had such an effect on me and i just
realized how many people it resonated
with through conversations i had about
it how many conversations it started for
me one of them with my daughter
and i just really thought you know
that's
that's something i want to be a part of
if if we're ever able to bring that to
the screen i know how much it meant to
me and how much it's meant to so many
people
and so i um i just feel really grateful
to have been able to take on that role
and really um
you know get to share evan and all of
the character's story with people yeah
it's a really important message right
now and what is it like for you i mean
it it's such a beautiful thing because i
talked to ben platt earlier and he's
like well i'm in awe of julianne and amy
they're these incredible actresses but
then i talked to julian and she's like
i'm in awe of ben i mean when ben platt
is singing at you in these scenes what
is that like
it's profound i mean that's what i just
keep telling
it's the one movie i've talked about i
can't talk about what ben did without
getting emotional because
he's so um invested and so present it
feels so personal and it is so many
people's story and it just
it's so moving um what he brings to this
role and what he offers
to you on the other side of a scene it's
it's just really beautiful
it is it really is and it's incredible
because it's almost like
seeing it now on film seeing his face up
close
um getting those emotions across what do
you think people will get out of the
movie that that makes it different than
what they got from the musical if they
saw it well i think the thing that they
they're they are able to capture that's
the same as this universality of the
message but i think being inside of the
experience allows
it just allows an intimacy that although
when i saw the play i felt a real
intimacy i think it's even deeper in the
in the film
in those scenes i don't totally know how
it works was ben ever singing for real
as you guys were filming always always
yeah i'm pretty sure it's yeah it's all
he was always singing yeah he's
immensely gifted
and i can see firsthand how hard he
works as well so
it's it's amazing the only thing was amy
i i wanted to see you singing more and i
didn't totally get that and
i was wondering did you miss singing at
all i mean we've seen you sing in other
parts
no no i mean i love to sing but i i also
love getting to be a part
of this story that is so much about the
experience of adolescence and the
experience of being a parent but
really getting to be there and help tell
this story about this time
and i get to sing plenty in my own life
so
do you sing at home
oh yeah yeah oh you do what are you
saying
uh
anything anything
yeah well my daughter she's 11 and she's
like mom please don't sing billy eilish
please don't don't ruin billy eilish for
me
you know
no you should definitely keep singing
billy eilish
i think so too but yeah
oh my i was wondering if one of you
might direct me to the castle watch it
william
grumpy
nobody's been very nice to me yeah well
welcome to new york
thank you
well you know i got to ask about a movie
i'm hoping we get to see you singing
disenchanted what can you tell me about
what it's been like to come back to that
role and and to reunite with patrick and
bring in maya rudolph
i it was so much fun we actually wrapped
filming so uh
we have done it it was amazing it was it
was um
it was really fun to get to revisit that
role that meant so much to me i felt
such a huge
love for her in her world we bring on
some new talent as well that's amazing
like maya who oh my gosh i love her so
much and getting to play off of her we
just have a really great cast there we
have all the um most of the original
cast that gets to come back and then um
like i said and then um
a couple of new actors playing the kids
and they're absolutely wonderful so it
was just a really great time and and
i get to sing a lot in that one so yes
okay good some new songs
yes
okay
what i mean all of us are such fans of
the original what what are we gonna kind
of get from the sequel how could you
tease it if at all
i probably should figure i should do
that
oh it's just it's
i'm like it's an extravaganza of
enchanted it's
it's even more enchanted which is the
name of a song in it so yeah oh
thank you yeah um has your daughter if
she has an issue with you singing at
home has she seen enchanted and does she
love your singing in that movie
she's seen it's been a while since she
saw it but yeah she's she's used to me
singing we we have fun with it she
teases me but um she's got a really good
voice so i try to encourage her to sing
but yeah she does do we have a future
entertainer on our hands i don't know i
think right now she just does it for
herself but we'll see she's kind of
she's more on the shy side
well that is awesome um we can't wait
for all of it uh you know and as as
you've said several times this movie i
think
gosh it's just so interesting because
when it first came out it was so
relevant right and then it's almost like
because of all what we've all been
through over the past year that those
feelings of isolation feel even more
important to discuss
how is that something that um i don't
know that you guys talked about on set
or maybe how have you kind of talked
about that in your own life as you've
been working on the movie
well
i think what was amazing is we
this was um
this was my first
uh film
back we were in quite quite a small
bubble and we were all sequestered away
from one another so our only time
together really was on set during the
scenes and it became
like the immediacy for connection was so
apparent um
it was really a special experience
inside of that
um inside of that time and
i think that uh
it just
sorry okay like
it it just was really um
it just brought to the forefront how
much we do need each other
um
and then having that connection on set
was so important um
not only
you know to the making of the movie but
just as as human to human at that time
in our lives
you